Is that they're promoting all the kindness
promoting on the fall once a day and
my five year olds, okay, but
what I'm saying is kindness.
Unless you're a right wing person.
Now, if you think on the right,
then they want to attack you,
then they want to do want to demonize
you and if they could shut you down and
silence you and find some
sort of a bullshit excuse to
do so. And a lot of cases,
it seems like some folks lean in that
direction and this is where it gets
dangerous because you can't,
it's like if someone says, Hey,
if I knew how to fight, I'd run in front
of Pizza. I just fuck everybody up. Well,
you'd be dead in a year because eventually
people are going to kick your ass and
kill you. You can't just beat people
up. Well yeah, one on one basis,
but it's the everybody
gangs up against you.
It's that childhood childish mentality.
I'll just knock this person out and
nothing else will happen. Like that's not,
you know, you're setting a whole thing
in motion. When you silence someone,
you're setting a whole thing in motion.
And this is something
that we're all learning.
This is what we have
to come to grips with.
Social media has only been around
for a really short amount of time.
It's only been around in this kind
of form for 10 plus years and we're,
we're figuring it out and these people
that think that they can just silence
people and shut people down without
it having a bad effect on all of us.
It's not right. It's not right. Well,
I appreciate you should be a path,
one of the empty spaces. Good. Eddie,
what do you think should be done about
the denial of the reign of terror of
censorship and said,
middling going on?
Uh, I don't know. Shit. You know,
all I know is that it seems that
the right is being censored a lot.
And when you look at the left and
how they've been acting, I mean,
they're acting like psychopaths,
like pick, you know,
putting signs up for late term
abortions and all that shit.
They're pushing that.
There's people pushing that AOC there.
It's, it's like someone who's trying
to get fired. You know when you're,
you have a job when you want to get fired.
I'm just telling you a four on the floor
who runs whole CIA squad and he said,
what do you think Alex?
It's like they want to lose.
What's the cyop but I don't know.
That's, it seems like they're trying to,
it's so bad.
It's so bad.
How much of that is influenced by people
that are trying to fuck with the whole
system? Imagine if this is like
stage five Russian influence.
Just get people to support later.
Like figure out a way to get people
to support super late term abortions.
Figuring out a way to get
people to Support Trans
Women competing as women with
no hormone replacement on one high school
were like some 25 year old dude's like
18 year old girls. He takes all the,
all the titles like now guys haven't,
you know, it's hilarious. It's hilarious.
Imagine if your daughter was up for a
scholarship and she had to compete against
some six foot five man who identified
as a woman wanted to play basketball.
I feel a, if you've, if you've
committed a crime, if you're a felon,
you can't chop your dick off.
I like the Japanese model.
They hey,
because I don't care if you're a trans
or you're dude, once people went,
I don't literally, I'm a libertarian,
don't act like I'm trying to suppress you.
But the Japanese said, Hey, uh,
you don't get the Trans destination unless
you chop the Johnson and the way goes
off and it's like, hey, you
get, taxpayers will pay for it.
You get that vagina bill and then you sit
there and do it. Leave like, you know,
I think there's a lot of people
that are legitimately trance.
That's not the problem.
The problem is them wanting to compete
as women and Martina Navratilova it just
caught a rash of shit cause she
was talking about it, you know,
to the famous tennis star,
she's talking about it that women are
breaking all these records and right after
she said that these kids, number one
and two were transgender. That one,
the girls high school track
meet and it's just, you know,
at a certain point of time you gotta
go, you gotta stop doing this. This is,
we're talking about combat as somebody
because they think they're another sex.
I sat in the same timeline,
I watched like bike races and running
races and soccer and, and high jumping.
It's a dude. Like he thought just
like this is, you're bigger than me.
They were like these six foot, $4, he was
soldiers were kicked my house. Oh Lord.
And the girl or like, I mean
that's, that's been a little
less man. Yeah, there's a,
there's some nonsense going on.
There's some people that are legit and
then there's some people that are just
legitimately crazy.
I mean there's like with everything in
life is people that are legitimately
trans and there's people that have no
man wants to see himself as a woman in a
lodge. Lodger neck shows
the Kimball's that happens,
that's their issue, whatever.
Or vice versa.
But like,
I'm going to watch NFL and like
we're supposed to like, you know,
like they had a women's NFL and it's
all guys and they say they're women.
It was like a thing. And even when last
year where the guy comes in with tattoos,
a big beard and it was
in the police report,
the guy had like a foot long cock
and he goes, do a cervix jam.
What kind of police report is this?
And the, the nurse said, Oh sir, uh,
I don't see a vagina.
And it was in the report.
The man had a foot long dick.
So she's supposed to mentally yoga.
Okay, well let me check all this and
decide that you've got all this. I mean,
it's just like,
it's mental illness man.
It's not that I hate somebody that
feels that they're a woman or a man or
whatever. That's the lie that like, Oh,
you need to accept this or you hate
ever imagine if all this ridiculous
propaganda really was like the very,
very highest level Russian
meme farm propaganda.
And this is why the people,
that could totally be a thing,
this the most posthumously leftist.
Even things like these babies being
resuscitated and then killed like that.
People wouldn't freak out when they
heard a guy talk about that kind of shit.
Imagine if this is all just designed to
make everybody go fucking crazy. Joe.
I wish it was the governor saying it
and then doing it and there's just one
point we're going to this transmission.
What is the end game?
What is the end game? Alex? We're told as
humanities, bad Humana's wrecking things,
but the very environmentalist groups
that doing this are all like weird
transhumanist,
anti human.
I'm old transhumanists if I really get
life extension but it's all at Oh you
die,
your upload to a machine.
I'm just saying anything you see
the big corporate media promoting,
they don't know what they're doing. I've
been around them, I've talked to them.
They don't know. I don't think
I know. I don't think Joe knows.
I don't think Eddie knows,
but I think in the spectrum of like
one to a hundred we're in the 95th
percentile.
If we're really being woke.